pour nous l'ensemble des éléments de cet
amendement sont satisfaits je vous
remercie pour
[Musique]
qui contre qui s'abstient et n'est pas
adopté je mets de voir l'article si ce
qui est pour
qui est contrebiens il est adopté un
article 7 une prise de parole Sylvie
Robert pour commencer
oui merci madame la présidente madame
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
alors nous voici ce que j'appellerai
peut-être au cœur du réacteur ou au cœur
de ce cheval de Troie comme certains en
qualifiés ce texte car l'expérimentation
la vidéoprotection augmentée pose
d'innombrables problématiques juridique
le respect des libertés et des droits
fondamentaux des personnes mais aussi
technologiques et industrielles qu'elle
souveraineté réelle dans la phase de
développement des traitements et quelle
assurance pour en limiter les biais et
bien évidemment mes chers collègues
sociétales et politiques vers quelle
société tendons-nous dès lors que
l'anonymat dans l'espace public est levé
et la surveillance globalisée avons-nous
collectivement conscience des
implications d'un tel renversement et y
souscrivons nous quelle garantie
établissons-nous pour nous prémunir
d'éventuelles fuites en avant à cet
endroit je préciserai que l'argument
utilitariste il peut apparaître fondé au
regard bien sûr des menaces sécuritaires
ne répond nullement à ces questions qui
interrogent pourtant notre pas commun
d’existence j'ajouterai que si cette
solution technologique complète un
arsenal sécuritaire déjà fourni elle
limite le risque mais ne l'efface pas
pour le dire autrement jusqu'où
sommes-nous prêts à consentir de notre
liberté pour préserver au maximum notre
sécurité
l'article 7 témoigne de cette recherche
d'équilibre particulièrement délicate à
trouver et à cet égard je tiens à saluer
le travail de la commission des lois qui
a mieux encadré le dispositif en boitant
le pas à la vie de la CNIL notamment
mais certains points mériteraient
éclairci et pourrait j'espère et
pourront faire l'objet d'amélioration la
durée expérimentation si elle répond au
risque sécuritaire démultiplier pendant
les JO P pourquoi avoir choisi de la
prolonger jusqu'au 30 juin 2025 soit un
an après leur fin l'évaluation de
l'expérimentation étant donné son
importance dans la perspective d'une
éventuelle généralisation doit présenter
toutes les garanties d'indépendance
qu'il est légitime d'attendre enfin
troisièmement un impact financier sur
les collectivités territoriales et les
organisateurs des manifestations et à ce
jour inconnues l'étude d'impact étant
très silencieux sur le sujet enfin
quatrièmement et j'arrêterai là
j'aimerais poser une question au
gouvernement pourquoi avoir élargi le
périmètre de l'expérimentation aux
manifestations culturelles et
récréatives j'y reviens alors ton patron
quand même parce que le texte vous avez
pas pouvoir lire beaucoup et quels sont
vos motivations je vous remercie de vos
questions
alors Monsieur Philippe Tabarro
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur président buffet
j'interviendrai un petit peu plus tard
lors de la discussion de deux
amendements l'article additionnel
concernant les transports néanmoins je
souhaitais intervenir au préalable pour
vous exprimer ma déception ma déception
car nous sommes en discussion d'article
et d'amendements intégrés au sein du
chapitre 3 nommé renforcer la sécurité
mais de quoi parle-t-on apparemment
seulement de vidéoprotection et de
traitement d'algorithme et c'est bien
mais l'ensemble de nos amendements
visant à renforcer la sécurité dans les
transports ont été déclarés irrecevables
au titre de l'article 45 j'en tire la
conclusion suivante renforcer la
sécurité oui mais dans les transports
non et je ne peux pas m'en satisfaire
alors qu'entre 2021 2022 les vols et
violences dans les transports en commun
ont augmenté sans parler du fiasco du
Stade de France nous devons muscler le
continuum de sécurité afin d'enrayer les
incivilités la violence et l'insécurité
qui règne dans nos transports c'était là
connaissance de nos amendements car oui
nous ne dormons pas de donnons pas
suffisamment de moyens aux acteurs de la
sécurité dans les transports à
l'occasion de la lecture du projet de
loi l'homme pile le ministre de
l'intérieur c'était engagé à renforcer
le continuum de sécurité la lecture
restreinte de ce projet de loi témoigne
bien du fait que nous soyons encore loin
d'un tel approfondissement j'espère que
les prochains textes notamment
d'initiative parlementaire permettront
que la peur change en fin de camp
deux amendements identiques de
suppression Monsieur Pierre aux olias
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre cet article 7 il faut dire les
choses de façon claire et du point de
vue du droit et de la défense de l'État
de droit c'est un dispositif qui est des
rocadeurs au rgpd c'est important de le
dire parce que jusqu'à présent la France
en Europe avait été en pointe pour la
défense du rgpd avec cet article 7 nous
reculons sur l'application du rgpd
notamment sur la base de l'article 23 du
rgpd la CNIL a consacré un travail très
important sur les caméras augmentées et
les vidéos augmentées elle a rendu son
avis le 19 juillet 2022 et elle
considère selon elle que par rapport au
rgpd par rapport à un certain nombre de
dispositions qui défendent en France
liberté individuelle la seule façon
d'autoriser des vidéos c'est de mettre
en place des mesures qui permettent la
suppression je cite quasi médiate des
images sources ou la production
d'informations anonyme or ce que vous
nous proposez dans ce texte c'est juste
l'information du public en aucun cas
vous vous permettez aux personnes qui
seraient filmées d'avoir un droit de
recours d'avoir un droit d'opposition or
pour la Cnil c'était un objectif tout à
fait essentiel qu'elle souhaitait voir
garantir par une loi spécifique donc
chers collègues il faut bien prendre
conscience que par le biais de cet
article 7 alors qu'il aurait fallu une
loi qui permette de définir aussi les
droits des personnes vous êtes en train
de tout doucement des tricoter le RGPT
merci madame la Présidente
le 63 Thomas dessus merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames les ministres j'en
ai déjà longuement parlé lors de la
défense de ma question préalable mais
nous sommes ici face à un cavalier même
je dirais un cheval de Troie législatif
visant à nous faire passer un cap dans
la société de surveillance globale les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
celui-ci qui a un prétexte pour jouer
aux apprentis sorciers avec ses
algorithmes de surveillance nous le
savons le marché est énorme il y a là
plus une opportunité industrielle pour
les entreprises du secteur qu'une
véritable attention à l'ordre public si
c'était l'ordre public qui nous
intéressait nous expérimenterions pas
des technologies absolument pas matures
lorsque nous avons échangé avec Madame
la Ministre des Sports elle m'a affirmé
que l'objectif était d'éviter un nouveau
Séoul en référence au drame ayant fait
plus de 150 morts dans un mouvement de
foule le soir d'Halloween en octobre
2022 mais sachez mes chers collègues que
la Corée du Sud expérimente les caméras
augmentées depuis
2020 ce ne l'a pas empêché ce drame
absolu d'autres raisons sont donc à
trouver mais nous nous mettons nous nous
exposons aussi un risque opérationnel en
effet si le système noi les forces de
l'ordre sous de faux positives de
notification d'aide à la décision qui se
multiplie on met en danger l'événement
mais nous profitons plutôt de cet
événement exceptionnel pour franchir ce
cap une loi d'exception qui vise à
pérenniser un coup de canif
supplémentaire dans nos libertés
publiques mais ça n'a rien d'inhabituel
puisque que ça soit Rio 2016 ou Tokyo
2020 les gouvernements les différents
gouvernements ont profité des JO pour
faire passer des lois d'exception et
mener des opérations sécuritaires
violentes la CNIL et le Conseil d'État
estime que le déploiement des
dispositifs prévus par l'article 7 dans
des espaces publics présentent
incontestablement des risques pour les
droits et libertés fondamentales
fondamentaux des personnes l'acnil
précise d'ailleurs qu'il est nécessaire
de se prémunir de tout phénomène
d'accoutumance et de banalisation de ces
technologies de plus en plus explosive
c'est pour ça que je vous propose de
supprimer cet article je vous remercie
la vie de la Commission du gouvernement
je vous informe que nous avons reçu une
demande de scrutin public sur ces deux
amendements madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente ce sera un
avis défavorable parce que effectivement
nous considérons que cet article 7 qui
introduit la vidéoprotection
intelligente ou les caméras augmentaient
mettent en place un dispositif certes
d'une innovation majeure mais qui
permettra d'aider à la décision
fortement les forces de l'ordre pour la
sécurisation de les grandes
manifestations sportives culturelles et
récréatives et a fortiori dans la
perspective des Jeux Olympiques c'est
une expérimentation c'est JO en seront
un accélérateur mais on voit bien
l'utilité eu égard à la fois au risque
terroristes qui est encore extrêmement
fort dans notre pays et à l'ampleur de
cet événement inédit que seront les Jeux
Olympiques notamment en raison aussi de
la spécificité de la cérémonie
d'ouverture ce dispositif est encadré
par de nombreuses garanties qui ont été
instaurées suite à la réécriture je l'ai
dit après la vie de du Conseil d'État et
de la CNIL et nous avons souhaité encore
à la commission des lois renforcer ses
garanties par un contrôle plein et
entier de la CNIL et notamment par un
contrôle au moment de la création des
algorithmes dans les fameux bac à sable
pour faire en sorte que il ne
remplissent pas les billets que vous
évoquez et que le contrôle humain reste
permanent pour s'assurer que ces
algorithmes pourront de déterminer ces
fameuses événements pour détecter pardon
et signaler ces fameux événements
prédéterminés et aideront nos forces de
l'ordre à être plus efficace et plus
opérationnel pour l'organisation des
grandes manifestations
merci avis du gouvernement
merci madame la présidente Madame et
messieurs les sénateurs en fait
effectivement ce dispositif qui est
prévu est un dispositif novateur c'est
la raison pour laquelle il est engagé de
manière expérimentale l'objectif c'est
de donner au gouvernement les moyens
d'éviter un certain nombre d'événements
alors vous avez parlé sur le sénateur de
ce qui s'est passé à Séoul pour
Halloween on n'a pas aujourd'hui
d'éléments tendance à démontrer que ce
dispositif expérimental a été engagé
dans le cadre de cet événement on a dans
l'histoire d'autres événements de
mouvements de foule qui n'ont pas pu
être détectés c'était le cas à Turin en
2017 c'était également le cas à la
Mecque en 2015 d'un événement dans
lequel on a eu plus de 700 morts et donc
l'idée c'est certainement pas on a
absolument pas de partie qui concerne
des informations personnelles avec
la reconnaissance faciale par exemple et
le gouvernement s'est appuyé sur cet
article sur le rapport du Sénat qui a
été produit en mai 2022 par les
sénateurs d'oblresses de Bénin et du
Rhin
prévoyez quatre catégories dans la
question du traitement algorithmique et
il n'est pas question pour le
gouvernement d'aller dans la quatrième
catégorie qui est souvent cité en
exemple qui est celle de la
reconnaissance faciale mais de se donner
les moyens tout simplement de détecter
le cas échéant des mouvements de foule
un colis abandonné éventuellement des
armes longues etc et donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de se donner les moyens là
d'assurer la sécurité pendant les grands
événements et puis la question de la
durée de l'expérimentation a été abordée
par un certain nombre d'entre vous là
aussi le gouvernement a besoin pour
évaluer ce dispositif d'avoir
suffisamment de grands événements
puisqu'il s'agit bien là de grands
événements à évaluer d'une part et
d'autre part pour entraîner l'algorithme
donc l'idée c'est de se donner
suffisamment de temps donc suffisamment
de grands événements pour pouvoir
évaluer le dispositif donc évidemment le
Gouvernement est défavorable à ses
amendements de suppression
pour une explication de vote
oui une explication de vote au nom de
mon groupe sur
ces deux amendements de suppression
contre lesquels nous voterons nous ne
sommes pas des fanatiques des nouvelles
technologies en matière de surveillance
et d'ailleurs très heureux que la
reconnaissance faciale n'est pas été
proposée dans cette émission parce que
ça n'est pas le bon vecteur ce texte
pour développer la biométrie avec la
vidéo
surveillance augmentée intelligente
algorithmique on l'appellera comme on
veut
c'est vrai qu'on passe à un cap et qu'on
développe dans ce pays pour un événement
qui est lui-même exceptionnel de
nouvelles technologies
nous avons fait le choix
d'accompagner ce mouvement en déposant
de très nombreux amendements
après le premier travail d'encadrement
qui a été produit par la rapporteur
Agnès canailler et qui est déjà très
sécurisant très solide qui vise nous
amendements à la durée d'expérimentation
à la qualité de l'information du public
à la déclaration d'intérêt des
prestataires extérieurs qui pourraient
être appelés à développer ces systèmes
au périmètre dans lequel c'est système
pour être mis en oeuvre l'effacement des
données non pertinentes qui auraient été
collectées pour ces systèmes à
l'indépendance des experts qui
contribueront à produire un rapport au
Parlement nous le souhaitons et donc
nous préférons accompagner le
développement de cette vidéo
surveillance augmentée dans de bonnes
conditions avec un bon niveau
d'encadrement dans un périmètre limité
pour que cette expérimentation nous
permet de garantir que
la puissance publique prend toute sa
responsabilité faute de quoi et nous
aurons le débat bientôt sur d'autres
technologies on risque de voir arriver
cette technologie à bas bruit de manière
rampante hors contrôle législatif c'est
le pari que nous faisons et les
amendements que nous déposerons et nous
défendrons dans quelques minutes
contribueront à nous indiquer si nous
votons favorablement sur cet article 7
ou non
la Présidente
chers collègues vous nous parlez
d'innovation technologique moi ce que je
vois là c'est surtout des innovations du
droit du droit c'est à dire des
innovations qui qui contribuent à
diminuer ce qui est l'État de droit et
notamment quelque chose qui est tout à
fait fondamental qui est le droit
d'opposition la CNIL vous l'a dit dans
son analyse et le texte n'apporte rien
dans ce domaine il y a simplement une
information qui est donnée mais il y a
pas de droit d'opposition et le droit
d'opposition c'est quelque chose qui est
complètement fondamental dans la gestion
des données numériques je vous le dis de
façon un petit peu un petit peu
provocatrice mais la surveillance à la
chinoise ce n'est vraiment pas notre
tasse de thé et quand on met le doigt
là-dedans on sait pas du tout on
s'arrête et si demain si l'État de droit
et la défense des libertés individuelles
deviennent un obstacle
à l'organisation des grands événements
sportifs alors il n'y aura plus que les
dictatures qui pourront les organiser on
l'a vu récemment avec la Coupe du monde
mais il y aura aussi d'autres exemples
et
bientôt les grandes fédérations pourront
organiser dans des pays qui sont
beaucoup moins regardons sur l'état de
droite ces grandes événements parce que
vous aurez une opposition massive à des
choses qui sont vraiment contraires à ce
que à ce qui est la défense de nos
principes merci Madame président
vous avez la parole oui merci madame la
Présidente
je suis
dubitatif depuis quelques minutes
Jeux Olympiques les épreuves de surf
c'est à
une petite commune là sur
Tahiti à 2h 2h30 de voiture depuis
propriété
tous ces dispositifs en matière de
sécurité je suis en train de me poser la
question et je posais la question à mes
collègues autour de moi mais comment
concrètement même à titre expérimental
comment concrètement vous allez faire
appliquer ça sous mes cocotiers enfin
une métaphore certains peuvent être
rigoleront parce que en écoutant tout ça
alors que nous étions enthousiasme et
nous accueillons mais à bras ouverts les
épreuves de surf sur notre territoire
mais depuis tout à l'heure j'écoute tout
ça je commence à avoir un petit peu peur
maintenant parce que si tout se
dispositif
venait aussi chez nous il y aura plus il
y aurait plus de comment dirais-je une
petite révolution parce que tous ces
soutenaient
encore voté au Parlement
la question que je pose au gouvernement
comment concrètement voyez faire
appliquer tout ça en Polynésie française
ou les épreuves de surf se dérouleront
divina roche c'est à vous
oui je remercie notre collègue
polynésien de son intervention qui est
très juste alors ce qui peut paraître
effectivement vraiment flagrant dans
votre territoire il est quand même aussi
dans les notes quelque part parce que
Sylvie Robert a très bien dit tout à
l'heure c'est un vrai problème de vision
de la société qui se pose c'est un vrai
problème de vision sécuritaire de vision
contrôlée de vision contrôlée par des
intelligences artificielles
artificielles de
big brother is wating you qui se pose
réellement aussi pour nous donc
accompagner un mouvement expérimental
certes je comprends ce que dit Jérôme
Durin mais dans la réalité la compagnie
ok mais pour aller où moi je ne suis pas
prêt et nous ne sommes pas prêts à
accompagner un mouvement qui décide un
modèle de société qui ne convient ni à
la Polynésie ni à nos territoires
français c'est pas le modèle de société
que nous souhaitons nous ne
l'accompagnerons pas
s'il n'y a plus d'explication de vote
nous allons donc procéder au scrutin
public je rappelle que la vie du
gouvernement et de la commission sont
tous les deux défavorables le scrutin
est ouvert
demande à voter
c'est pas fini ils ont pas fini
faites monsieur de colle vous votez pour
vous-même ou pour votre groupe
personnellement vous n'avez pas ok plus
personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est
en 331 exprimé 331 pour 28 contre 303 le
Sénat donc pas adopté
nous passons à deux amendements
68 tomate dessus
oui donc cet article qui prévoit un
traitement algorithmique des années du
vidéo de surveillance le fait sur une
durée limitée ce qui pose un certain
nombre de problèmes en termes de liberté
publique alors dans son avis du 8
décembre 2022 la CNIL estime que ses
outils d'analyses automatisés des images
peuvent conduire un traitement massif de
données à caractère personnel ce qui
comporte un risque d'atte à la vie
privée et au droit fondamentaux et
au-delà du caractère scandaleux d'une
expérimentation qui touche nos libertés
publiques on parle d'expérimentation de
ces outils sur une durée donc limitée
mais qu'en est-il réellement loin d'être
une mesure circonscrite au seul Jeux
Olympiques et par olympiques ce dont
nous devrions discuter aujourd'hui cette
expérimentation s'étend de la
promulgation de la loi jusqu'à un an
après la cérémonie de clôture des Jeux
chercher l'erreur alors que les jeux ne
sont prévus que sur deux mois on se
retrouve avec une expérimentation qui
dure deux ans révélant les véritables
intentions du Gouvernement une fuite en
avant techno sécuritaire on veut gaver
nouveaux algorithmes de données
l'utilisation de ces dispositifs dans le
simple cadre des JO et paralympique est
en soi problématique mais de tels
délaisse extensifs sont dangereux c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de les ramener à
un cadre temporel plus raisonnable
correspondant à l'intitulé de ce projet
de loi c'est-à-dire la durée des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
pour par rapport à cette amendement moi
j'estime que Madame le Ministre et
l'intervention de Jérôme Durand ont
défendu cet amendement puisqu'ils ont
expliqué qu'on était dans le cadre d'une
expérimentation mais qui dit
expérimentation dit qu'il y a un début
et une fin donc nous on considère que
c'est assez logique puisque c'est prévu
que l'expérimentation débute dès la
promulgation de la loi parce que ça
permettra comme le disait madame le
ministre d'avoir un certain nombre
d'événements pour expérimenter les
choses et comme nous le disait la
présidente de la CNIL pour pouvoir
affiner et conseiller les fabricants et
les de d'algorithmes mais en même temps
cette expérimentale expérimentation
comme vous l'avez très bien dit madame
la ministre doit servir à évaluer et
pour évaluer à un moment donné il faut
s'arrêter et donc on considère que il
faut s'arrêter après les Jeux Olympiques
pour permettre une évaluation et ne pas
avoir le biais qui peut qui peut
apparaître dans un certain nombre de
propos qu'en fait on aurait le projet de
loi avant même d'avoir évalué alors
évaluons d'abord et puis on verra après
voilà les prix de cet amendement
avis de la commission
merci d'avoir la présence ce sera un
avis défavorable sur ces deux
amendements qui visent à réduire
effectivement le temps d'expérimentation
sur cette vidéo protection intelligente
effectivement qui dit expérimentation
dit durée limitée dans le temps mais qui
dit expérimentation dit aussi évaluation
il faut que l'évaluation elle puisse
être fait dans les mêmes conditions que
la mise en œuvre de l'expérimentation
donc il est important de continuer à
au-delà dans un délai raisonnable de des
Jeux Olympiques pour que les algorithmes
puissent continuer pardon à s'entraîner
et qu'on puisse véritablement évaluer
sur ces données d'apprentissage qui
fonctionnent et sur des algorithmes qui
sont en cours d'utilisation d'une part
et d'autre part il convient aussi
d'étendre l'expérimentation jusqu'à un
délai qui dépasse le temps de
l'évaluation pour laisser le temps au
Parlement de se prononcer pour savoir
s'il convient de pérenniser ou non
l'expérimentation sinon elle tombera de
fait et qu'il n'y aura plus lieu que le
Parlement se prononce donc le système
proposé d'expérimentation jusqu'au 30
juin 2025 avec rapport remis 6 mois
avant et un bon équilibre
je vous remercie
madame la ministre
mais ma vie Madame le Ministre ok je
vais donc mettre au voie madame de La
Gontrie pour une explication de vote et
puis pierre au zodiaque après
merci madame la Présidente j'attendais
avec beaucoup d'intérêt l'explication du
gouvernement parce que
non mais je vois bien que vous fiez à la
vie de la rapporteur mais dans ce cas là
ce n'est même plus la peine d'occuper le
banc du gouvernement
qui n'est pas d'accord
non plus sérieusement on est sur un
point qui est essentiel qui est la durée
de cette prétendue expérimentation et ce
que beaucoup appellent le cheval de
Troie c'est-à-dire qu'en fait au
prétexte de l'expérimentation vous
mettez en place pendant deux ans un
dispositif qui n'est pas nécessaire
pendant deux ans d'ailleurs si vous
voulez entraîner les algorithmes puisque
j'ai compris que c'était ça le terme
il y a la Coupe du monde de rugby donc
vous avez tout loisir d'expérimenter les
dispositifs bien j'indique tout de même
que en fonction du sort qui sera réservé
à nos amendements sur ce point même si
la rapporteur a travaillé et la
Commission a travaillé de manière
extrêmement précise et complémentaire et
améliorer le texte notre groupe sera
amené à modifier le vote sur l'ensemble
de cet article donc encore une fois
madame la ministre moi je suis un esprit
simple je ne comprends pas comment par
quel raisonnement il faut prolonger
pendant deux ans une expérimentation
pour pouvoir l'évaluer donc c'est sur ce
point et sur la nécessité de cette
prolongation un an après les JO que je
souhaiterais pouvoir connaître la
position du gouvernement pierre rosulias
l'acceptabilité sociale des Jeux
Olympiques si nos citoyens ont
sentiments que quand un pays organise
les Jeux Olympiques c'est matière à
problèmes de circulation problème de
santé problème de transport problème de
congés et aussi problème de sécurité
encore une fois il refuseront
systématiquement les Olympiques et Paris
sera la dernière ville qui les
organisera merci madame la présidente
Sylvie Robert
oui merci madame la Présidente oui mais
la même ministre moi je voudrais que on
soit quand même extrêmement attentif à à
cette expérimentation que d'aucun
d'ailleurs ont qualifié de changement de
paradigme même civilisationnel donc je
ne suis pas du tout
convaincue par la rapporteur qui nous
dit il faut prolonger parce qu'il faut
évaluer pour que les que les algorithmes
s'entraînent alors moi je vais lui poser
une question très simple c'est que
jusqu'au à 2025 qu'est-ce qu'il va y
avoir comme manifestation qui vont
permettre
d'entraîner ces algorithmes parce que
quand même la cohérence intellectuelle
voudrait que nous fassions
l'expérimentation nous arrêtions
l'expérimentation juste à la fin des
Jeux Olympiques qu'ensuite on évalue
qu'en fonction de l'évaluation après
bien sûr on revienne devant le Parlement
pour voir s'il y a généralisation il y a
quelque chose que je ne comprends pas et
tout à l'heure pardon madame la
Présidente vous m'avez à juste titre
coupé dans ma parole sur article j'étais
trop longue et j'avais demandé à la
ministre pourquoi est-ce que on est on
est temps au manifestations sportives
culturelles et récréatif cette
expérimentation moi j'aimerais avoir la
réponse parce que je peux vous dire
qu'après les débats que nous avons eu le
miloculturel et là j'ai un certain
nombre de messages n'est pas du tout
rassuré des débats que nous avons eu sur
le sujet donc je crois que c'est
vraiment important que vous puissiez
madame linis nous donner vraiment des
précisions et des explications sur ces
amendements du Bénin roche
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre nous ne souhaitons pas cette
expérimentation pour les raisons que
nous avons déjà évoqué ou que d'autres
ont fait ici mais en commission des lois
j'étais déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
exactement comme pierre ou Julias en
fait si à Fort retourner si c'était
sénateur qui avait proposé parce que ça
n'était pas dans le texte d'augmenter la
période d'expérimentation
un an ou deux ans après les Jeux
Olympiques on aurait déclaré notre
amendement il recevable c'est le texte
qu'il est irrecevable pour nous c'est un
vrai cavalier législatif le vrai
cavalier législatif qui consiste à
changer un certain nombre de règles de
notre droit concernant la sécurité
lors du passage ici au Parlement de loi
sur les jeux olympiques et le résultat
en dehors de changer le paradigme il est
très clair c'est que dans quelques
années au cas aucune ville aucun pays du
monde sauf les dictatures seront
capables d'organiser des Jeux Olympiques
[Musique]
et merci sur la question de du cavalier
très clairement la question du
traitement des mouvements de foule dans
l'organisation de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques étaient au cœur des
préoccupations du gouvernement donc là
le traitement de de cet article répond
justement à cette préoccupation là
ensuite sur la question de la durée ça a
été très bien expliqué et c'est pour ça
que je m'en suis remise à la vie de leur
rapporteur la question de
l'expérimentation c'est d'avoir le
maximum de données pour pouvoir faire
une évaluation et je rappelle que le
rapport sera remis 6 mois avant la fin
de la période expérimentale et d'avoir
le terrain le plus large possible et le
et on parle exclusivement de grands
événements donc il est clair que il nous
faut une certaine durée pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir évaluer correctement le
dispositif ensuite sur la question de
l'élargissement aux manifestations
culturelles et récréatives c'est une
demande du Conseil d'État qui a souhaité
là aussi pour élargir le plus possible
et pour permettre d'avoir une évaluation
la plus claire possible rajouter aux
manifestations sportives qui avaient été
proposées initialement par le
gouvernement les manifestations
culturelles et récréatives
merci je vais donc mettre au voie ses
amendements qui ont tous les deux reçoit
une nouvelle vie défavorable le 68 qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et n'est
pas adoptée le 21 qui est pour qui
contre qui s'abstitienne n'est pas
adopté lequel nous passons 44 je me suis
fier
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre
le mécanisme que nous examinons ici n'a
rien à dodain puisqu'il s'agit
d'autoriser l'utilisation de traitement
algorithmique en matière de vidéo
surveillance les bouleversements
qu'introduisent cette expérimentation
déjà été soulignée d'ailleurs la
commission des lois en a conscience
puisque le texte qu'elle nous présente a
déjà intégré des mécanismes de contrôle
supplémentaire dans cette perspective
nous permettons de rappeler la prise de
position de la CNIL qui souligne que les
conditions d'application à cette
nouvelle technologie des règles
relatives à la protection des données et
des principes protégeant les droits
fondamentaux sont en partie incertaine
ou à construire de sorte que face aux
incertitudes nous croyons que ce
dispositif doit être strictement limitée
et encadré l'article introduit deux
conditions retenues alternativement pour
que le dispositif puisse être engagé
l'ampleur ou les circonstances de
l'événement seulement comme nous ne
savons pas comment seront interprétés
ces critères par les administrations et
les juges peut-être serait-il
raisonnable dans un premier temps de
renforcer ces critères aussi
l'amendement proposé propose d'en
rajouter un troisième le caractère
exceptionnel de l'événement avec une
telle condition par exemple les
rencontrer hebdomadaires des
compétitions nationales de football ou
de rugby serait exclu en revanche des
machesix des matchs exceptionnels tels
que la réception Stade de France de la
Ligue la finale de la Ligue des
Champions mai dernier aurait pu rentrer
dans ce dispositif
la commission
avis défavorable la Présidente nous
comprenons la volonté de sécuriser au
maximum et c'est ce qu'on a tenté de
faire à la commission des lois mais
encore faut-il que ce soit opérationnel
et l'événement exceptionnel ce sont pas
forcément ces événements là qui sont
ceux pour lequel il y a le plus de
risques on peut penser au marché de Noël
au marathon au 14 juillet etc donc on
pense que véritablement rajouter cette
condition là ne permettra pas de rendre
opérant ni de couvrir l'ensemble des
événements auxquels sont destinés la
vidéoprotection intelligente avis du
gouvernement
avis défavorable du gouvernement
effectivement comme ça a été dit par la
rapporteur le caractère exceptionnel est
pas toujours celui qui manifeste le
risque réel c'est à dire qu'on a des
manifestations qui sont régulières mais
qui pour par leur caractéristiques
particulières nécessite ce type de
dispositif et qui sont pas forcément
exceptionnels donc le rajouter
limiterait le champ le champ des
possibles et donc avis défavorable du
gouvernement je mets aux voix double
avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'absède n'est pas
adopté le 43 Bernard Fiona
cet amendement pour tuer les mêmes
objectifs que le précédent c'est-à-dire
renforcer les contours juridiques du
recours aux algorithmes pour endimiter
l'usage et donc pour y parvenir nous
proposons de rendre cumulative les deux
conditions d'ampleur et de circonstances
qui permettent de désigner un événement
on voit bien quand les proposants
alternativement les limites seront très
difficile à tracer on trouvera toujours
une circonstance pour dire qu'il fallait
activer le dispositif je pense donc
qu'il faut avancer prudemment et
progressivement et donc limiter tout
risque d'excès en faisant ce cumuler
l'ampleur et les circonstances et de la
Commission
défavorable c'est le même raisonnement
que l'amendement précédent gouvernement
mais ma vie je mets aux voix double vie
défavorable qui est pour qui contre qui
s'absède n'est pas adopté le 60 mains
dessus merci madame la Présidente nous
sommes très attachés à la notion
d'héritage de ces JO nous souhaitons que
ces JO laisse une trace pérenne dans
notre pays mais nous n'acceptons pas la
politique du pied dans la porte nous
n'acceptons pas que dans l'héritage il y
est dans le l'héritage lié à la société
de surveillance nous pensons pas qu'il y
a de nécessités absolues à déployer
cette technologie nous ne sommes pas
dupe il y a dans la démarche
expérimentale que nous propose ici un
moyen d'habituer la population à cette
nouvelle étape de la surveillance
globale premier problème du traitement
algorithmique des images issus de la
vidéo surveillance tant le Conseil
d'État que la CNIL considère que ces
traitements algorithmiques représentent
une menace pour les droits fondamentaux
des individus d'après la CNIL ces outils
ne constituent pas une simple évolution
technologique comme on essaie de nous
vendre depuis tout à l'heure mais une
modification de la nature des dis des
vidéos pouvant entraîner des risques
importants pour les libertés
individuelles et collectives et un
risque de surveillance et d'analyse dans
l'espace public la CNIL précise au
passage qu'il est nécessaire d'empêcher
tout phénomène d'accoutumance et de
banalisation de ces technologies seconds
problèmes l'utilisation des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle est
aujourd'hui dépourvu de cadre légal
propre dans le droit national comme dans
le droit de l'Union européenne une
proposition de règlement européen sur
les systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
est en cours d'élaboration mais rien
n'existe à l'heure actuelle nous ne nous
l'aurons pas devant l'objectif à peine
volet du gouvernement détendent la
portée de ses dispositifs par le droit
la durée extensive de l'expérimentation
dont nous venons de débattre et le
contenu du texte sont autant de preuves
de la volonté de pérenniser ces
expérimentations parce que nous refusons
la banalisation de ces dispositifs
sécuritaires face aux risques des
dérives potentiels et dans l'attente
d'une actualisation de la réglementation
européenne nous proposons donc
d'inscrire expressément dans la loi que
cette expérience n'a pas à être
pérennisé
quelle est la ville de la commission
avis défavorable effectivement
il faudra nécessairement une loi pour
assurer la pérennisation de
l'expérimentation donc en aucun cas ça
ne se fera de manière automatique donc
en fait votre amendement est satisfait
gouvernement
même avis effectivement le principe le
gouvernement a opté pour le principe de
l'expérimentation qui donnera lieu à une
évaluation et donc un passage le cas
échéant devant le Parlement pour pour
une pérennisation mais je rappelle
également que quand même ce texte suit
les préconisations de la CNIL d'une part
et d'autre part que la CNIL sera informé
des conditions de mise en oeuvre de ce
dispositif et je rappelle également que
le dispositif est sur la base des
préconisations de la CNIL pardon soumis
à des garanties extrêmement fortes des
garanties en matière d'une part du fait
que cette expérimentale d'autre part que
c'est utilisable uniquement pendant les
grands événements d'autre part que il y
a des garanties sur l'utilisation du
logiciel en matière d'information du
public en matière de conservation des
données en matière de contrôle humain en
matière de formation des agents et ça a
fait l'objet d'un amendement de leur
rapporteur adopté en commission à des
garanties également sur les algorithmes
avec un décret qui est pris après avis
de la CNIL avec une garantie qui prévoit
que seul l'état puisse réaliser un tel
dispositif et puis je le rappelle à une
garantie parce que c'est bien le préfet
qui détermine en fonction de la
manifestation du territoire géographique
et d'un certain nombre d'éléments si oui
ou non ce dispositif peut être utilisé
donc toutes ces garanties permettront
d'une part permettre d'une part de
cadrer le dispositif d'autres parts de
d'avoir une expérimentation la plus
efficace possible
la rapportrice de de vrai savoir de quoi
je veux parler en fait c'est pas idiot
de dire que ça peut pas automatiquement
être généralisé parce qu'en fait il y a
certains d'orbes d'expérimentation qui
ont été généralisées avant l'évaluation
les cours criminels départementales
c'est cette année on est un exemple on a
généralisé la cour criminelle
départementale une expérimentation avant
même qu'elle soit évaluée et d'ailleurs
si on l'avait évalué avant on l'aurait
peut-être pas généralisé donc le fait de
préciser que c'est pas automatique
ça me paraît une bonne idée très bien
merci je on voit double avis défavorable
qui est pour qui est contre qui s'abset
n'est pas adopté nous avons 97 de
Monsieur Théophile qui est un amendement
rédactionnel qui vise de mettre un
accent circonflexe si leur rapporteur
n'y voit pas d'inconvénient et le
gouvernement non plus nous et si
personne se pose il était adopté mes
chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance non non monsieur dessus vous
pouvez voir ça je vais suspendre il est
20h
voilà et
elle sera reprise à 21h30 pour la suite
de ces travaux